hi I'm Laurie vos I'm the CEO and
co-founder of NPM Inc and my job title
right now is CEO but don't take it too
seriously they just needed to give me a
title because I'm a co-founder and that
one happened to be available what I am
is a web developer I've been a web
developer for 22 years and that's what I
think about that's what I care about and
that's sort of what I'm talking about
today I'm talking about NPM and the
future of JavaScript those two things
are closely related these days because
we're JavaScript gos affects what NPM
does and these days what NPM does kind
of affects what JavaScript does so this
talk is going to have three port parts
first I'm gonna tell you what you should
know about NPM there's a bunch of
essential NPM features some of which are
pretty new and a lot of people haven't
heard about them yet so I'm just going
to go through them quickly and then I'm
gonna tell you what NPM knows about you
we do a lot of research we have a lot of
data we do a bunch of surveys we know
stuff about JavaScript developers that
JavaScript developers don't necessarily
know about themselves so it's hard to
know if you're a JavaScript developer if
something is genuinely popular or if
there's something is just getting a ton
of hype and we know so we can tell you
and that should help you make some
technical choices and then finally I'm
going to talk about the future of
JavaScript which is a very dangerous
thing to do because who the hell would
have thought five years ago that this is
where we would be today but nevertheless
I'm going to go out on a limb and make
some predictions to try and help you
make the technical decisions about what
is going to happen in the near future
with JavaScript so let's get started the
first thing that you should know about
NPM is that these days NPM is
ridiculously popular NPM has more than
10 million users and they download
nearly 6 billion packages a week we
think about 85% of all the people who
write JavaScript are already using NPM
and that is rising rapidly to 100% like
it's you know there's always gonna be a
couple holdouts but at this point nearly
everybody is using javascript is using
NPM to do it and that's even more
amazing because by some measures
javascript is the most popular
programming language in the world right
now is the biggest language on github by
a long way and it is and 70% of people
in Stack Overflow survey of developers
this year said that they program in
JavaScript so if you put those two
numbers both together and you believe
those numbers which is not you might not
necessarily that means something like
over 50% of all working programmers use
NPM today so the next thing is that NPM
is being used everywhere javascript is
being used and javascript is being used
everywhere people are building websites
and javascript obviously they're also
building server-side applications in
node but people are doing like robotics
and IOT in javascript because it turns
out the java scripts just kind of easy
to do and all these people are using NPM
to do it all of those fields have NPM in
them as well which is why NPM s growth
is so big this is not just like the
growth of web development or the growth
of node it's the growth of that and
robotics and you know every other frame
work that happens in JavaScript these
all contribute to this ridiculous amount
of growth a 10:00 p.m. so NPM is the
package manager for all of JavaScript
but above all NPM is for web developers
93% of NPM users say that they are
writing code for the browser 70% of them
also say that they are writing code for
the server so it's not like it's
entirely a web browser thing but let's
that it's a huge shift in how we think
about ourselves NPM you know the N and
the P and the M they stood for node
package manager don't ask Isaac but like
that's what we thought of ourselves when
we started the company and that's not
what we are now NPM is the way that
people put websites together and we've
had to change how we think about
ourselves and we've had to change how
NPM works to reflect that 97% of the
code in a modern web app is downloaded
from NPM you as the application
developer only write the final 3% all of
the interesting parts are the final 3%
and all of this up a giant pyramid of
stuff that you're standing on top of
comes from NPM the current version of
NPM is 6 if you are still in version 3
or 4 which 40% of you are then you are
woefully behind the
it is time to upgrade those are the
instructions it will take you 30 seconds
well it won't take you 30 seconds if
you're using version 3 it'll take you
like five minutes don't do it right now
though because I'm using the Wi-Fi the
big reason to move to version six of NPM
is that version six of NPM is 20 times
faster than version 4 was that is not a
typo it is 20 times faster if your build
takes 20 minutes right now it will take
30 seconds using NPM 6 you should really
try that out is it faster than you or
more accurately all the package managers
are about the same speed now because of
a triumph of how open-source works the
makers of PMPM and yarn and NPM they all
got together and they created an online
community so that he could talk about
building package managers which it turns
out quite a few people are doing and
that place is called packaged dog
community which is a URL these days
because it's 2018 and the result was
that all of these package manager makers
cooperating with each other they made
all package managers faster when they
made them all faster by roughly the same
amount so now they're all basically the
same speed they're all much faster than
they used to be but they're all about
the same speed
sometimes NPM is a little faster
sometimes yarn is a little faster but
it's never so much faster that you'd
notice anymore but being faster is
probably the least exciting thing to
happen in NPM recently the biggest
change is that NPM six locks by default
that was one of the big features people
liked about yarn and it is a good idea
because you all have trees that have an
average of a thousand modules each in
them and so the semver drift in a
thousand modules is pretty huge so you
want to lock it down and make sure that
what you've got on your development
environment is exactly what gets
deployed to production and that is what
package lock does and it just happens by
default and you don't need to think
about it another small change but a nice
one is that you don't have to type - -
save anymore
if you just npm install something it's
automatically saved into your projects
because you were installing it you
probably wanted to keep it if you didn't
want it you can uninstall it I don't
know
that wasn't the default the whole done
NPM six also introduces something called
NPM CI this is an alternative way of
calling NPM install that works
particularly well in continuous
integration environments continuous
integration environments have some
specific features that meant that we
could throw out a bunch of logic that
existed in normal NPM installs and the
result is that NPM CI is twice as fast
as a normal NPM installed so if you were
using you know if you're upgrading from
NPM four and you're using NPM six and
you run NPM CI
it was twenty times faster and then it
got twice as fast again so it's 40 times
faster so you should really be getting
on that it's what I'm saying
so as NPM has got bigger security has
become an even bigger concern for us
earlier this year NPM acquired lift
security that was new we've never
acquired anybody before that felt like a
grown up a grown up company thing to be
doing and the first thing that we did
was incorporate the node security
platform directly into NPM itself and
the result has been a bunch of new
features that we're super happy with the
first of our security features is to
factor off two-factor authentication you
can set it so that could be published
with 2fa and only with to efface so that
you know that even if somebody steals
your credentials nobody can pretend to
be you and publish a malicious package
while pretending to be you which we're
gonna talk about more later because
you're thinking of a specific package
right now in May we launched quick
audits when you download and run and
when you run NPM install and you
download a bunch of packages these days
you will automatically get a bunch of
messages on your console that will tell
you whether or not the packages that you
are installing are secure at the moment
we decided that we're not going to stop
use installing insecure packages because
there's some sort of line to be drawn
between convenience and security but
eventually we should probably do that
right like if we know you're installing
something that's broken we probably
should stop you this works in nearly
every version of NPM but an NPM six the
security warnings are going to be more
detailed and more
useful these quick audits obviously
because they're happening by default
they're happening a lot and they're
turning out to be super popular we do
about three and a half million quick
audits every week the stats around these
audits are not great right now eleven
percent of the scans that we run reveal
that somebody is installing packages
that have a critical vulnerability in
them that is the kind where you were
supposed to drop everything and fix it
immediately and 37 percent of them have
a high vulnerability we don't
necessarily know if you're installing a
package with a high vulnerability that
your code is vulnerable so don't run it
to Twitter and go like oh seven percent
of web apps are vulnerable now 37
percent of web apps are using a package
that has a high vulnerability in it they
might not be using it in an insecure way
but if they're using ones with the
critical vulnerability in them it's hard
to use them in a non dangerous way those
11 percent those people are probably in
trouble and we should talk to them but
fortunately fixing all of that stuff
just got a lot easier because running
NPM audit will give you a detailed
report about your web app of the
vulnerabilities that exist in your app
and how severe they are and often what
to do about them and often the answer
when you when you need to tell somebody
how to fix their insecure web app is you
just tell them you should upgrade from
this insecure version that you're using
to the secure version because generally
by the time that somebody has reported
an insecure version of a package that's
because they found out about it and so
they fix it so nearly all insecure
packages have a secure version that you
can upgrade to and the way that you do
that is run NPM so if NPM is the thing
telling you to run NPM why does an NPM
just run itself and fix it for you
that's exactly what it does now NPM
audit fix not only will it download and
install all your packages for you and
tell you if they're insecure you will
fix them for you if it turns out that
they are insecure it will just magically
get that right it's amazing I don't know
when we turned from being like a thing
that downloads stuff and puts it on your
hard drive - for you - a thing that
fixes your software for you but you're
welcome by default it will only prank
bring in semver compatible changes so it
will bring in stuff that it thinks
doesn't break your software but you
shouldn't trust us you should be running
your tests anyway but if there are
breaking changes that come in you can
force it to bring in the breaking
changes as well with - - force then you
should definitely be running your tests
because it is definitely going to break
you but it's better to be secure than
broken right another big change in MPM
recently is that we shut down our github
tracker
NPM is one of the world's largest open
source projects and what we love github
the issue tracker was just not scaling
to meet our needs it was becoming kind
of a vortex of sadness where people
would throw issues and we couldn't find
them because there were 10,000 of those
bastards and there's nothing we could do
so now we have a discourse there's NPM
community which is also a URL because
20:18 it's sort of a combination of an
issue tracker and a forum you can sort
of help each other and you can also see
what feature development is being done
and you can track where progress is
going and it's in general just like a
million times better than using github
missions for this kind of thing so you
shall have a head over there and check
it out another new NPM feature in NPM 6
is npx this is a convenient little sort
of side program that lets you run any
command on the registry as if it was
already installed on your computer
without you having to download and
install it this is super useful for
commands that you just use once in a
while and that you would not need to
that you don't want hanging around on
your computer all the time so you can do
like npx create react app and it will
download and install create drags app
that will run react app it'll create
your every art app for you and then it
will tidally delete itself and vanish
back into the ether leaving you with
only a react app and not this annoying
tool hanging around npx has a ton of
features I've given a whole talk that is
just about the stuff that you can do
with npx so you should absolutely check
it out as you can tell I could go on and
on and on about all the features of NPM
because I work on it all day and we're
super happy with it there are a few
quick ones I didn't mention you can get
your own scope for free you can get an
open source organization for free you
can use you should be using run scripts
to save you time
and you can use NPM in it to standardize
your application setup if you're not
familiar with any of those things now is
the time to Google them but I'm not
going to talk about them today but the
one last thing I am going to talk about
because people keep asking is how does
that be in make money are you some kind
of charity like we had a super friend
came to visit us the other day and like
he is a super fan like he follows us on
Twitter and is constantly up in our
Instagram why do we have an Instagram
he's like he loves us and like one of
his first questions was like wow this
office is really nice how does the
charity afford this and like oh come on
no we're a company the registry costs
millions of dollars a year just to keep
up and running just the servers and
bandwidth so we are a company because
only a company could generate enough
revenue to keep the registry going and
growing the way that it is does so we we
earn money by selling certain services
and goods that people like private
packages and security services and you
should really look into them if you have
this talk is not going to be about
plugging them so it's time to move on to
what NPM knows about you first off how
do we know all of this stuff in the
first place there are two big ways first
every time you download stuff from NPM
you hit our servers and you know you
request stuff from us so we know what
computer you're coming from and what
operating system you are on and what
version of node and one version of NPM
and what packages you were downloading
because that's what you were doing and
we also just asked you directly we ran a
survey at the end of last year we asked
16,000 people what they what they're
doing with JavaScript and how they feel
about NPM and a whole bunch of other
stuff and they just told us because
you're all nice and 16,000 responses to
a survey get some very interesting data
I don't know how much you care about
data but I care about data getting an N
equals 16,000 survey is like Christmas
morning which is funny cuz it happened
on Christmas morning we ran it from
December through January so the results
are fascinating but first I want to try
a party trick and I just wrote this talk
and I've never done it before so I have
no idea if this is going to work so this
could be cool or it could be super
embarrassing I would like everyone to
stand
if you can so I'm gonna say some things
about you and if those things aren't
true you can sit down again so first
stay standing if you use NPM good stay
standing if you write and JavaScript in
a browser you write JavaScript didn't
work you're concerned that maybe the
open source code you use isn't always
secure you mostly taught yourself
JavaScript you didn't learn it at a
bootcamp or at school or anything okay
that was all what I was expecting now
it's gonna get tricky in addition to
JavaScript you also write PHP or Java
sometimes still a bunch of you standing
you work at a company that doesn't
really consider itself a tech company
you started using NPM less than two
years ago still got most to you not most
of you you're using webpack and Babel
you are writing a reactive using type
scripts I've still got some people look
at all that stuff we knew about you
isn't that cool so there you go we know
a bunch of stuff about you you can all
sit down now that is how much stuff we
know about you I could go down there a
zillion other paths that I have gone
down about that but that is how much
stuff we know about you but I went
through it all really quickly so let's
go back and explore that stuff a little
bit as we said earlier most people using
NPM to build websites 70% are using are
also writing server-side JavaScript and
81 percent of you primarily use
JavaScript at work so you're not using
you're not just doing it as a hobby
project this is the thing we run into
with investors alike ah JavaScript for
hobbyists No
No everyone is doing it at work none of
this is gonna be a surprise to most of
you
the other finding is that NPM users
aren't only writing JavaScript that was
kind of a surprise nearly a third of you
write Java and another 30% of you write
PHP Python c-sharp and go are also
popular days many NPM users don't really
consider themselves JavaScript devs at
all they use NPM to get stuff done and
they write some JavaScript but they
consider themselves primarily some other
kind of developer and javascript is just
this thing that they do because you need
to build a website and how do you build
a website without writing JavaScript so
that was surprising but it probably
shouldn't have been because we know that
the programming language that you pick
is determined primarily by the libraries
available in that language and the
reason we know that is because somebody
did an academic study about it and he
like is it you know why do people pick
programming languages it lizard-like the
language features is it performance is
it the language that they're already
familiar with is it you know the thing
that their office picks for them know
the primary predictor of what
programming language you use is is there
a library in this language that will
help me do the specific thing that I'm
trying to get done because we're lazy it
turns out that laziness is our primary
predictor it turns out that we will do
whatever do we what whatever we had can
to not have to write some code as
programmers and that's exactly what the
data says people are picking JavaScript
because the libraries in NPM get help
them get stuff and there are 750,000
libraries in the NPM registry now and so
that is an enormous number of things
that can help you get stuff done so you
would expect that 750,000 libraries
would have people bending over backwards
to be able to use them and that's
exactly what we're seeing right there's
this huge pile of tooling and these
annoying frameworks you have to put up
with and you are putting up with them
because delicious delicious libraries
are just sitting there waiting to be
incorporated so you don't have to write
anything my favorite part of this is
there's a sad 15 percent of people who
say they don't use what program they use
those people are mostly Ruby developers
it turns out
another important finding is how big how
big a concern security is to most users
in the registry 77% of said it was and
even more concerning ly 52% of people
said that the existing tools for testing
whether or not the open source libraries
they were using were secure were not
adequate v half of people are like not
only does this suck I can't do anything
about it
that was bad news for us so that's why
we've been adding all of these all of
these security features because you know
the data said that we should so now
would be a good time to mention NPM
Enterprise I promise this is the only
other plug in the talk if you were a big
company and you were worried about the
security of your JavaScript's first off
good idea it is scary out there
and secondly we can help you with that
NPM enterprise service will give you
your own registry on your own domain you
can point everybody at and suddenly you
know exactly where all of your code is
coming from and you can keep the nasties
out and you can get reports about what
nasties did get in plus a bunch of other
great security features but like I said
I'm not really here to plug NPM another
thing we learned is that 45% of NPM
users also use yarn and the also there
is important nearly everybody who uses
yarn also uses NPM sometimes very very
few people only use yarn and that's okay
like I said yarn with some excellent
open-source work we collaborate with
them it's fantastic and I used to say as
long as you're using the NPM registry
and the yarn uses the NPM registry I
don't care which tool do you use I don't
say that anymore the thing that people
really like to yarn for was the speed 71
percent of people who use yarn said that
the speed was the thing that brought
them to you and now they are the same
speed but what NPM has is to factor off
and it has security audits and it's
safer that's what we've been putting all
of our energy into this year and so I
can say with my hand on my heart I'm not
just you know I am biased but I'm not
just because I'm biased like NPM is a
safer tool to use the new yarn and 77%
of you say that you care about
that so you should probably be using you
should probably be using NPM these links
are a blog post about a company that
moved from NPM to yarn and stayed in
yarn for like 12 months and then decided
that they hated yarn and moved back to
NPM and they wrote that tool at the
bottom which lets you migrate a yarn
project back to NPM that's what you want
to do you can get these slides you can
get that link and you can check it out
there are a few more interesting
demographic facts about NPM users one is
that NPM users are mostly very new I did
that in the intros I was like if you've
been using it for less than two years
about half of people who use NPM have
been using it for less than two years
which is interesting because only about
a quarter of people have been using
javascript for less than two years it's
a bunch of people have been using
javascript and are still only just
finding out about NPM NPM is still
inhaling this huge wave of people who
are embracing modern JavaScript we also
looked at whether NPM users tend to work
at a particular size of company or in
any particular industry we got a
negative result but if you're a
statistician negative results are also
interesting about half of NPM users work
at companies less than 50 people and
that sounds big but actually that's just
the distribution of companies most
companies are under 50 people half of
companies in the US are less than 50
people and that's where you work we've
got a similar negative result with the
industry forty five percent of our users
say that they work in tech and the other
55% say that they don't but what is a
line for a tech company is Google a tech
company because if you're asking people
at Google what industry they work in
Google people work at in advertising and
they also work in media and you know
some of them work at a car company so
what is a tech company anyway
the results they were strange so that's
who we are that's all of the information
did the demographic stuff that I got
about you but what I promised you is
information to help you make technical
choices and for that we need to look at
the tools that you use and we have a
great deal of information about what
tools that you use but before I get into
that I should I should say that that one
of the things about developers is they
get really passionate
they're tools passionate in a sort of
good and bad way if I tell people that
their tool is unpopular and they really
like that tool they tend to get really
defensive and angry at me and I'm like
I'm just reading numbers this just stats
on the screen don't yell at me I don't
have a dog in this fight I'm not saying
your framework is bad I'm just talking
about relative popularity if you want me
to tell you that your framework is bad
that is what the after-party is for so
before I show you these angry making
graphs let's put this in context this is
how the registry furrows I showed you
this graph already I want to show it to
you again I want you to bake it into
your mind because this these numbers are
going to be weird to look at if you're
not thinking about the context of
registry that grows 10% month on month
for everything the registry has grown
11,000 percent in the last four years so
the fact that the registry is growing
means that new users are constantly
showing up there is just a firehose of
new users all the time which means that
every package in the registry grows
month on month in absolute terms even
the shittiest packages are constantly
getting new users because there's just
so many new users and they're all just
bumping into the walls I'm like oh this
thing deletes my files that's great I
want one of those like every package in
the registry is just growing out of
control see that line at the top that's
Express wait yeah that line at the top
that's Express Express is bedrock to NPM
practically everything that people build
with node and involves Express this is a
graph of express using the metric that
I'm about to show you we call this
metric the share of registry it is not
how absolutely popular Express is right
expresses absolute popularity goes like
that but expresses relative popularity
relative to all the other packages in
the registry is going like that because
there's so many other packages in the
registry right now and read and Express
is a really old package Express used to
be 1.5 percent of all NPM downloads all
by itself and now it is 0.1% 0.1% sounds
like not very much but it is 4.8 million
downloads a week 0.1 percent of
of NPM downloads is winning the lottery
if you are a package author so it is
just relatively less popular and all of
our metrics are going to use this graph
it shows how the packages are growing
relative to each other not relative to
absolute number of users so first let's
take a look at some front-end frameworks
starting with the oldest which is
backbone as you can see back in 2013
backbone was the [ __ ] everybody was
using it but basically nobody uses
backbone now and by basically nobody I
mean 250,000 people a week right
weeds collapsed in popularity but NPM is
like this and so 250,000 people a week
are still using backbone despite the
fact that nobody uses backbone anymore
the thing that you can see here more
than anywhere else is a pattern of how a
framework dies very few people switch
frameworks especially within the life of
a project they keep all the frameworks
around and they build new stuff in the
new frameworks and then they slowly
retire the old software so frameworks
they don't fall off a cliff they just
have a half-life they slowly decay
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
that is how packages become unpopular so
nobody's writing new software and
backbone wrote lots of people are
maintaining existing backbone projects
hands up if you are maintaining an
existing backbone project there you go
you're all of the back sorry about that
so now let's look at react react is
goddamn running away with the web right
now 60% of respondents to our survey
said they were using 60 we're using
react 60% of NPM users and there are a
lot of you say that you're using react
that is some huge usage and some
impressive growth but it's not runaway
growth that's the interesting thing
about this graph right it's not going
like that come on like this what's up
with that
why just react seem to be slowing down a
little bit is that temporary is it gonna
pick back up next year let's look a
little bit further
one obvious thing to check is whether
Reax growth is being slowed by people
adopting pre act instead pre actors our
drop-in replacement for react which has
all the same features but is much much
faster because they dropped support for
slightly older browsers is pre act
sucking up reacts users is that's what
is that what's going on
it's certainly growing superfast you can
see that in the in the first graph but
relative you know it is the red line at
the bottom of the second graph it's not
actually going to be that big in
absolute terms so we should probably
appeal to where angular is an extremely
popular framework back in January about
40 percent of users said that they use
react this is where my math gets hazy
because about two-thirds as many like
60% said reacts 40% said angular that
should be about two-thirds as many but
our graph doesn't say that our graph
says about half as many people are using
angular so who's lying is my graph lying
or the numbers lying there's probably
some haziness here lots of people who
use angular use it in enterprise
environments and they have like internal
registries and or something that might
be why angular appears to underreport
itself the angular community certainly
came up with a bunch of reasons they
were not happy with me telling them that
their problem that their framework was
not popular so I am NOT gonna say that
certainly not in public ever again I
don't actually have enough data to be
sure of that because all I have is this
graph of downloads and that's not
reliable what I do have is one data
point of asking people and next year I
can ask people again so next year I will
know for sure because either more or
less people will tell me that they're
using angular but right now all I can
say is that downloads peaked in 2017 and
are beginning a slow decline ember is an
unusual story Enver was pretty popular
in 2015 and then it had sort of a rough
patch but in 2017 and 2018 it's making a
comeback and that's unusual I've never
seen a framework do that before I've
never seen a framework turn around to
the decline that's strange it's unusual
but it seems some really healthy growth
now in January about 4% of NPM users
reported using ember but now you can
expect that number to be about doubled
at about 8% roughly as popular as ember
right now is view but view has a very
different growth story view is just
taking off so if I had to guess why is
react growth slowing down I'd say it
looks like it's going to view I think
that's probably where the Worthen the
newbies are going I don't have a perfect
picture there are zillion other
frameworks that could be doing this but
this is what it looks like to me
now does this data suggest some
technical choices for you I think it
probably does but I'm not gonna get into
them right now instead I'm gonna go into
some more data and we're going to do the
predictions all at the end so let's talk
about the react ecosystem react is a way
of making components that share state
there are a lot of applications that do
that kind of stuff and we use react to
do it there's like mobile apps and
desktop apps and rich web apps but rich
web apps have an additional requirement
which is that they need to map URLs to
specific pieces of functionality if
you're building a mobile app and react
you don't need to do that if you're
building a web app you do so react
router is a separate package that lets
you do the routing and much like Reax
itself reacted or grew quickly and has
now leveled off but the interesting
thing there is that react router has
about half as many users as react itself
because the two are decoupled and it is
one of the triumphs of reactor they
managed to successfully decouple those
functions one of the reasons react is so
popular is because the makers of react
decided we are going to solve one
problem only we're gonna make a really
great component library about state and
we are not going to bother with all of
the other stuff that the other
frameworks deal with and that means that
the choices that they made when they
were good got to succeed on their own
merits and the choices that they made
that they were that were bad failed on
their own merits and they all failed and
succeeded separately so Reax is more
than twice as popular as react router
because there are lots of react apps
that don't need a router and speaking of
react decoupled model let's look at flux
flux was released by Facebook and
roughly the same time that react was
flux was how Facebook thought that you
were going to use data in a react app
it's how Facebook uses data in a react
app and it turns out that nobody likes
it it turns out that the very second
that there was something that could
compete with flux people abandoned flux
on mass and that thing is Riddick's
Redux as you can see as soon as Redux
started taking off flux started
collapsing because it turns out people
like Redux better it's a way of managing
state in your application that's more
ergonomic Redux and reactor outer track
each other because they're a very
popular combination they almost go up
and down when they each go up and down
mob ex is a competitor to redux that had
a promising start and nobody seems to
care about it anymore
and then there's our XJS i confess i do
not know what is going on here
our ex jeaious is another state
management system it competes with flux
and redux it is growing it bewildering
speed it is currently more popular than
react itself and how is that possible
how can a thing that works would react
be more popular than react it's because
it doesn't only react it works with
other things as well the angular CLI
uses rxjs to manage state within the
angular CLI so all of angular's users
are also using rxjs
but this growth is weird this growth is
so fast for such a packet of packages
it's so big that there has to be
something else going on so I'm probably
gonna have to do more research here I
mentioned graph QL earlier graph QL like
RCS started in react land and expanded
it is red hot right now there are two
big libraries you for using graph QL
they are Apollo and relay but as you can
see apollo is taking the cake apollo is
the one that is taking off and relay is
just sort of doing okay so far i spent a
lot of time focused on front-end things
because like I said 93% of you but 70%
of you were also doing back in things
let's talk about backend things for a
little bit over in backend frameworks
there's really just one thing happening
which is express everybody's using
express all of the other ones don't even
show up relative to Express it's just
tremendously popular what if we took
Express out of the picture what does
everybody else look like in blue you can
see qooco is a sort of spiritual
successor to express written by the same
people who have sort of mature as
developers and changed their preferences
about things it's Anna bouncing along
it's not getting a lot more popular in
relative terms but remember not getting
more popular in relative terms means
it's in absolute terms Co is growing
like this right anything that's looking
flat on this graph is actually going
like that in absolute terms so Co is
doing very very well
[Music]
sales as the name suggests is a straight
up court of Ruby on Rails to node as
bass suggests this seemed like a good
idea at the time
as people get more comfortable with
server side dais they are looking for
frameworks that are more sort of
idiomatically javascript e and that
seems to be weighing on sales people are
not using sales as much anymore because
they have once stuff that is more Java
Script e happy is a framework that NPM
used to use we recently switched to
react for our own website and in the
blog post about that switch we made the
tremendous mistake of mentioning that
one of the reasons we switched is we
didn't like happy very much
or rather we didn't like some of the
design choices made by happy and that
made the designer of happy very angry he
sent me some vicious emails oh my
goodness so I'm never gonna say that in
public again
as you can see Happy's growth is
relatively flat which means that in
absolute terms it's doing very well and
then there's a bit of an oddity which is
next yes from the makers of site next
yes is a sort of kitchen sink framework
for react so if you you know if you like
reacts but you wanted something that
does everything for you like angular or
ember does you can try out next I said
it'll set up the router and the build
chain and all of the pain-in-the-ass
tooling for you and I really like this
idea so why does the graph make it look
like it's not taking off it is taking
off the reason it looks strange is
because next the package used to be a
different package they adopted it from
somebody else whose package is in
decline so if you only look at it since
the zeitgeist oook it over you can see
the next it's actually growing really
really nicely so how is everybody doing
so far I've just been throwing numbers
and graphs at you for 20 minutes now is
everyone doing ok excellent all right
I'm gonna try a thing now everybody on
this side of the line is team a
everybody on this side of the line is
team B let me hear it from team a team B
team a team B
right I'm not gonna use that for
anything it's just to wake you up so I
talked to ton about frameworks but a big
part of what people use NPM for is to
help with their build chain and their
tooling like everything else there's
some fascinating data here and I'm gonna
dig into it because you know awake again
because people started shouting and you
were like oh my god I should stop
checking my email people are shouting
the first thing to know about tooling is
that everybody hates it everybody wishes
there was less tooling everybody wishes
there was less configuration everybody
wishes the documentation was better
people are kind of pissed off about
having to do this tooling in the first
place and the only reason you put up
with it is 750000 delicious delicious
libraries that's what keeps you coming
back despite them having to set up all
of this stuff that you hate first of all
what kind of tooling do you use 85% of
us use web frameworks of some kind
that's compared to the 93 percent doing
front-end so eight percent of you were
just rolling your own good jobs 74
percent of us are using transpilers 69
percent nice are using linters 67
percent are using bundlers 58 percent
are using CSS preprocessors and 58
percent are also using testing
frameworks so let's break that out
because that is all interesting
frameworks in general not web frameworks
just all frameworks expresses of course
at the top then reacted in the
everlasting jQuery followed by angular
and then a surprise appearance by
electron 24% of you are building
electron apps that is much bigger than
we thought it was electron is being used
to build desktop apps and mobile apps
and it is hugely popular hands up if
you're using electron for something
there you go it's about a quarter of you
isn't that weird you don't think of
yourself as being like this big chunk of
the JavaScript community but you're a
quarter of the JavaScript community
these days electron is a massively
popular project and then this view and
Cohen backbone won't die pre-act happy
next hands up if you use meteor in the
room anyone using meteor in the room
once okay
it's still there apparently and then
ember Brown and now let's look at
transpilers transpose the tools to
translate other languages into
JavaScript the most popular one is of
course Babel which is mostly translating
JavaScript into other forms of
JavaScript with the biggest ception
which is GS x which is j sx is not part
of javascript but at this point it sort
of feels like it should be because
everyone's using react and everyone's
using it and it seems to be written in
JavaScript all the time why doesn't
JavaScript have JSX as a first-class
feature maybe the standards body should
get on top of that CoffeeScript is
clinging on and Allen closure scripts in
there but the big surprise is typescript
46 percent of you are using typescript
that is much bigger than we thought it
was going to be that was a huge surprise
half of people in JavaScript aren't
writing JavaScript anymore they're
writing typescript what the hell is that
I'm seeing two people would type script
things on their on their shirt so you
weren't surprised
so typescript for the other half of you
is it's a form of sort of built in
testing it adds types which helps large
teams work together by having a sort of
built-in check that you're doing things
correctly Microsoft launched typescript
with its own package manager and the
community got pissed off with them and
rebelled they were like just put them in
NPM we do not want to have to run to
package managers this sucks so Microsoft
took their advice which is very new
Microsoft of them but also like new
Microsoft they didn't ask first they
just launched typescript 2.0 one day and
said hey all of the packages are an NPM
now we were like what so now in addition
to its job as being the package manager
the package manager for all of
JavaScript NPM is the official
repository of all typescript types which
is not a job we asked for but thanks
Microsoft it's cool we have all sorts of
special logic in the registry to deal
with when typescript decides that it's
going to publish an update to the types
package and it publishes 5,000 packages
in the same second it was like okay
we're gonna line you up and do you one
at a time in your own special build
queue so that the rest of NPM doesn't
grind to a halt when that happens
linters as 70% of you know our tools
that will tell you if your code is nice
they will check for obvious errors and
they will flag
they will flag or even correct coding
styles for you they're super popular and
by far the most popular is yes lint and
you may have heard about es lint
recently because there was a security
incident with the eslint very very
recently like a week ago
eeeh slit-like most open sources
maintained by a group of volunteers and
those volunteers are mostly very
experienced developers with professional
development habits so nearly all of them
had it enabled to factor off on their
npm accounts but one of them had not one
of them was using a simple password and
even worse they had used that password
on another website before that other
website got compromised and somebody got
that list of compromised passwords and
tried it out on NPM and it works and
suddenly they had access to publish es
lint one of the most popular packages on
the registry the thing that they did
with that package is they published a
version of es lint that if you
downloaded and installed it it would
steal your npm credentials so that the
attacker could then publish stuff is you
this is a nightmare scenario right
because like if he can if the attacker
can get your credentials then they can
publish back - this is you creating more
compromised packages which can then
compromise more people could have
created a runaway effect kind of a
disaster scenario but what actually
happened is that people noticed really
really quickly within 30 minutes of
people noticing we'd taken down the
offending package an NPM security audits
were warning everybody that this was
happening
and the result was that as far as we can
tell and we are still double-checking
very very seriously nobody else got
compromised apart from the official
first official developer because the
community landed on it so fast and so
hard and like they took down the paste
bin and they yelled at everybody like
NPM as its own is his own immune system
we also reset the login tokens of
everyone prior to the incident because
we couldn't tell which tokens had been
stolen so all of the tokens prior to
last week are destroyed so if your
builds aren't working that's why
but this is why NPM is taking security
so seriously this is why I talked about
all of the security features because the
bigger we get the more [ __ ] show up
and the more [ __ ] show up the more
somebody is likely to do something evil
and malicious just for kicks so now it
is possible to enforce 2fa on a package
you can say not only am I going to only
publish this package or 2fa nobody else
who has access to this package can ever
publish it unless they also have 2fa
enabled the eslint folks would have
benefited from that feature last week
but at least it exists now and you have
to use the NPM 6 to do this so that's
another very good reason to upgrade but
back to our tooling stats bundlers are
things that take your JavaScript and
pack it up into a single files that it
can be delivered and run on a browser
they are essential to react in the other
frameworks so 67% of you are using them
because you know 60% of you are using
react and then there's another 7% on top
that are using it for other stuff except
80% of people report themselves as using
webpack which means that more people
then know what a bundler is are using
webpack they didn't know how to answer
the previous question but if we ask them
if they're using webpack they're like
yes yes I'm using that thing 20% of you
are using browserify and 10% are using
roll-up and finally in the stats let's
look at testing frameworks a great deal
of you are using mocha jasmine is also
very popular gest is understandably
popular given its ties to react and how
popular react is but sitting up there at
number 3 is none come on 21% of you
can't be bothered to do any testing at
all surely we can do better and that
brings me to another interesting part of
this data which not only can you do
better the data says that you will do
better we first noticed this effect when
we started looking into security
practices we noticed how we looked at
how developers approached security and
we split them up by how long they had
been a developer and there was this
really great linear progression the
longer you've been doing javascript the
more likely you are to care about
security and we discovered that this was
true for nearly everything that people
would consider a best practice so this
is just comparing the most experienced
group with the least experienced group
there was a clear line across the groups
in all of these cases so bundling
linting various security practices they
all increase in a nice smooth linear way
the longer you've been doing stuff so
they all that says is that the more the
more experienced you get the better you
will get it as a developer the data says
it the data says that this is what you
do so you will get better at security
the data says you're going to this was
particularly evident in security only
about 58% of the newest devs use
security features of any kind but in the
most experienced group it's 85% and you
can get yourself into the yes group by
just upgrading to NPM six right if you
have great two NPM six you can say yes I
use security scans because they happen
every time I install whether I wanted to
want them to or not so thank you all for
being so patient we're nearly at the end
I'm massively over time I think we come
to the future of JavaScript this is the
part where I must make the predictions
that I said that I was going to make at
the beginning how am i doing for time
yes I'm actually over time all right
this is the part where you can take
pictures of me standing in front of a
slide where I make a prediction that
turns out to be wrong that's what these
are for exactly that is what predictions
are for predictions are for making me
look like an idiot so the biggest
prediction I can make and the month and
the one most likely to be accurate is
that nothing lasts forever backbone was
once dominant and it is now an
afterthought jQuery which gave web
development so much power let's all hear
it for jQuery it was wonderful
jQuery has been superseded which is not
a thing we ever thought would happen any
framework or tool that exists today has
a heyday measured in a handful of years
like three to five that's about how long
any if any individual framework is going
to stay popular then they're gonna have
this long lingering afterlife where they
slowly slowly degrade so don't cling too
tightly to your tools that's the first
thing that you can get from this don't
be the person using jQuery in 2018
because there's so much better now
on the front-end frameworks I'd it would
be unwise to bet against react certainly
for the next few years react has a ton
of users and more importantly react has
a ton of modules as I said before
language choice is driven by the
libraries available people put up with
all of this crap tooling stuff because
they love the libraries in NPM and react
creates reusable components of that you
can use in your web app so if react gets
this right
if react fulfills the promise like
there's a there's a module in NPM built
by a friend mine called react color you
just install it and you've got a color
picker in your app you've got the UI and
the UX and the JavaScript and everything
and it just works it's amazing that is
the dream of react just download and
install chunks of your app so you don't
have to write them if react gets that
right react will create the same
self-reinforcing cycle where you know
react people will adopt reacts to be
able to use these components that will
make them rank more components which
will make more people show up and react
will have the same kind of runaway
growth that NPM did if react gets that
right react will be unstoppable I'm not
going to predict that it will however it
might not make it but if it does it will
go forever and the reason I don't
predict that it will because we've
already seen react is kind of slowing
down what's up with that is it view view
certainly has momentum could it just be
that react while very flexible is not
flexible enough to cover 100% of web
development news cases that might well
be it it might well be that there is no
single framework that is going to be
good enough to build every webpage in
the world in it and that react is just
sort of hitting the ceiling of how
popular
possibly be I would certainly predict
that I would certainly predict that
there is no framework that is going to
win we're not all going to end up
writing one framework forever but in the
meantime what should you do react has
the users and that's a big deal when it
comes to picking a framework you want to
be where everybody else is because they
will fix the bugs for you they will
write the tutorials for you they will
answer your questions on Stack Overflow
if that's where everybody else is it's a
safe place to be angular has the support
of Google and it is popular in the
enterprise especially among people
running Java on the back end if Google
continues to support it it's never going
to go anywhere right like it's just
gonna stick around forever so angular is
a safer but less interesting choice than
react view has the momentum it is going
places it is definitely the new hotness
will it have the staying power it is too
early to tell I wouldn't bet on it down
ember has a bit of everything ember has
a fair number of users it's got good
corporate support it's recently gotten
some new momentum I would take a look at
it and if it seems nice to you I have no
problem with you using ember I would not
you know recommend against you easy
thing ever and keep an eye on neck j/s
like I said I would bet on react and
next jest is react but with all of the
pain removed so I think next year's is a
really good idea so if you're looking to
something to get your mind around
something new to learn I predict a graph
QL is about to be huge there are whole
startups are built around graph QL
people are getting funding and built
around graph QL now and it has some real
advantages if you build api's you should
be luke you should be investigating
graph QL and finding out if graph QL is
going to help you build that API faster
or better when it comes to bundling
transpiling and nothing I predict that
you will do them
because as you gain experience the data
says that you're more likely to do them
if you're not doing them already webpack
seems likely to keep bundling for the
next little while
yes Lin is almost certainly going to
keep it sold on lending and Babel is
probably going to be the transpiler you
all use but don't forget about
typescript that was a shocker if you
haven't looked at typescript and if
you're not sure that type scripts for
you 46% of people seem to think it's
adding some values their lives so it's
probably worth looking at these days one
obvious question coming out of that
prediction is what happens to NPM if
people stop writing JavaScript and the
answer is nothing because that already
started years ago and you didn't even
notice a big percentage of the modules
on NPM have native code in them so you
use them in your java scripts but
they're actually in there you're
downloading and installing a c code
which is compiling itself a bunch of
them are written in es6 which isn't
really Java Script yet react is written
in is react is written in es6 es6
doesn't run in a browser react can't run
in a browser by itself it trans files
itself before it runs in your browser
and you didn't even notice that probably
that react is written in not JavaScript
and one of the most exciting
developments on this not javascript
front is was OMA or web assembly to the
rest of us web assembly lets you write
in any language like compiled languages
like c and rust and trans file them into
JavaScript except it's not just
JavaScript it's not JavaScript like
babel does java scripts not just other
javascript it's a special subset of
JavaScript that can run as fast as
native code so the promise of wiesen is
you can run rust and you can put it in a
browser it will run just as fast if you
were actually running rust on your
desktop that is super exciting that
promises to be a way to give web apps
native like web performance and the best
part is that it's already here watson
pack is a tool from mozilla that lets
you write code and rust and compile it
to Azzam and then publish it to npm
there are already some packages up there
some of which you might already be using
that are actually writing native code
and running it in your browser and
you're using it in your javascript
without even knowing that that's what
you were doing that could be where NPM
ends up going everybody is still using
NPM but javascript is no longer the lang
there and that brings me to my other big
prediction which is no matter what end
what happens NPM is here to stay
if JavaScript stay big stays big or if
we all end up writing rust in the
browser whatever happens the huge pile
of delicious delicious libraries is
going to keep us on npm every new system
is going to be backwards compatible with
the old ones and we're not gonna leave
those libraries behind because they're
too good there's no way we're leaving
them behind
so no matter what happens to JavaScript
NPM will still be the way that you build
the web I've been doing web development
now for 22 years and it has always
thrilled me and no time lesson right now
the stuff that we can do on the web is
amazing and wonderful and the tools that
we can use to make it our ad hoc and
partially finished and kind of a mess
and my final prediction and biggest
prediction is that's how it's always
gonna be we remake the web so quickly
that it's never done that's how you can
tell that the web is growing and popular
is that it's never stayed still long
enough for us to catch up and finish
writing the documentation it's always
people racing ahead where the rest of us
going oh god we have to use that new
tool now that's why the web is exciting
because it's never ending and it's never
changing so I hope that you stick with
it for the next twenty two years and
thank you very much
[Applause]